hello
my name is brian parman i'm the ag
finance specialist in the department of
ag business and applied economics i work
in for extension
and today as you can see from the title
slide i'm going to be talking about
backgrounding budgets and profits
this particular talk we're going to be
looking at steers and heifers
running looking at several scenarios in
terms of
average daily rates of gain
um as as
so different feed rations as well as
fattening or growing them up to
different weights for both heifers and
steers
using current feed costs and prices as
well as current market prices
and so as i go through this uh obviously
keep in mind that
um
what we're trying to do here is is see
both a if there's some money to be made
fattening or or background in calves
as well as what is the sort of the
optimal scenario and that's kind of what
i'm what i'm hoping to hit on uh and
again this is a lot of these are
projections so when i go through the
prices here we're taking today's prices
and just kind of projecting
with no real
expectation of of price movement too
much one way or another
all right so compared to last year and i
gave this a similar talk uh last year on
backgrounding budgets and did some
different scenarios but
the the feeds the feed price situation
is a bit different this year
for one thing
fall crop prices are much higher this
year than they were last fall
we had a situation here in north dakota
last fall where we had a lot of low
quality wheat
that our our farmers weren't really sure
what to do with and you might have been
able to purchase some of that and feed
it uh at a relatively low cost
hay prices are are
slightly
elevated for for like grass hay a little
bit lower for alfalfa hay and i'll show
you that in a minute trucking and
shipping costs and yardage costs uh in
these scenarios uh remain mostly the
same as last year
not a lot of movement in those those
costs and then cattle prices for feeder
cattle are a bit higher than last year
but not dramatically uh we're kind of
you know if you'd uh
looked at prices last spring you know we
might have been thinking that feeder
calves were going to be fairly cheap but
prices rebounded uh quite a bit and so
this fall we're kind of we're in a
similar situation where we were last
fall
around this time in terms of the price
of feeder calves
so when you're thinking about
backgrounding obviously whether you keep
your own or you're going in and
purchasing them we charge ourselves the
market price for whatever 500 or 600
weight calf that we're we're retaining
because obviously you could have if they
were your own you could have taken them
down the road and sold them and and
received whatever whatever the market
price was so you got to obviously charge
yourself that
so
this is the corn pr price of corn i was
talking about and i just wanted to show
a chart of corn prices uh and this is on
a continuous contract basis over the
last three years
and this fall
you know if you see here on the right
um is not not uh not the peak the peak
was uh there in 2019
uh especially the early part of 2019
where we had that
4.54.80 corn for a for a period of time
we're not nearly that high obviously the
beginning of 2020 when the pandemic hit
for covid uh corn prices went down to
nearly three dollars but here this fall
we're seeing in over four bucks so
and then if you compare it to last fall
it was more like 380 so corn prices are
elevated uh relative to last year that's
that's for sure
so this is this here is the 2020 alfalfa
prices from usda uh this they just they
collect average prices for uh and then
they rate it premium good fare
what we would typically what you'd
probably typically feed beef cattle is
going to be in that good or fair range
um so
our near our nearest neighbors south
dakota for good hay
128 to 180 bucks a ton and then for fair
a lower protein content maybe closer to
uh 16 percent or or 14 protein 103 to
113 dollars per ton
um for alfalfa and then we also have
montana here uh similar uh maybe
about the same as as what you're gonna
see in south dakota so i'd use those as
a proxy for for hay prices across north
dakota is these uh these montana and
south dakota prices which are tracked
here
and and
again i'm going to show you on the next
slide but how alfalfa price is down
perhaps a little bit uh over last year
and here it is
2019 versus 2020 alfalfa hay prices
here's november 12 2019
we had uh montana at you know 110 to 180
and then 80 to 150 on this end so again
it's a range but they're not
dramatically different and then if we
look uh here
and then also south dakota 175 to 225
and then this year 128 to 180 so alfalfa
is is lower especially the south dakota
market than than what was seen last year
so
if you're thinking about feeding
obviously feed costs are a big deal
they're extremely important so we have a
higher price of corn this year
and a lower price in alfalfa
and then grass hay grass hay prices are
similar to last year's prices but again
they're slightly elevated
for whatever reason alfalfa is a bit
cheaper than last year grass type hay is
a bit more expensive than last year but
not dramatically so pretty much your
your hay costs i would expect them to be
roughly if you did any background in
last year roughly what they were uh the
year before
corn on the other hand not so much with
with corn prices being as elevated as
they are
so here's my cost price assumptions as
i'm as i go through this is i've got
grass hay at 75 bucks a ton we're going
to be using you know the high-end affair
to good uh alfalfa hay prices here's
corn silage corn grain at 380 a bushel
um that would be if you know if you're
growing it and you're looking at cash
prices yes i know spot was closer to 420
but cash
you're not going to get that not up here
so 380 ddgs 160 a ton limestone bag salt
and then some pre-mix yardage we're
charging 35 cents a day that's what they
charge at carrington
we have this budget online that i'm
going to be going through and you can
change the yardage if you want to and
and you you may see other budgets
that have much higher or much lower
yardage fees it really depends on how
they break out the cost i've seen some
instances where feed costs are included
in the yardage so you'll see this really
high yardage cost of maybe a dollar
fifty a day or something like that well
if you throw the lump the feed in there
then that makes sense trump trucking at
about 75 cents a hundred weight and then
you got your vet costs and i'm just
going to use a shrink and death loss of
three percent and one percent
respectively as we go through here
so six different scenarios uh three
steer scenarios and three heifer
i'm gonna do the the first deer one is a
1.8 pounds 80 average daily gain and
we're feeding from a 500 weight and to
an 800 weight and then 2.8 pounds on a
steer from 525 weight to 805
and then this one we're basically
finishing going all the way from a calf
to 1270 pounds at a really high rate of
gain of 3.6 pounds
and then heifers uh we're running two
scenarios at 1.8 pound uh adg
and that's from 450 to 750 and then 550
to 850.
okay so that's 1.8 pound and then a
higher rate of gain uh 2.8 pounds from
525 to 805 on the heifers
so i'm going to go through these
six scenarios and we're going to look at
the profitability uh under each case
so we'll start with steers we'll just
run through the the steer feeding
scenarios first and then and then again
we'll go through the the heifer
scenarios
all right so the prices that i'm using
are from the uh
usda auction summary for north dakota
so here's the average across the state a
summary ending november 13th so when
you're thinking about okay so what am i
going to put in for my cost of a 500
weight steer i'm going to put them at
167 dollars a piece that was the average
so if i'm going to background the steer
my upfront cost is going to be 167
dollars per hundred weight and then when
i go to put in the
actual prices or the the revenue
expectation let's say we're going to
uh 850 pounds roughly i'm going to use
this 139 uh dollar range now if i'm
going to 800 weight
now maybe one i'm going to use this 128.
so if i'm going to 800 pounds i'd use
this 128 at uh 850 800 plus
or 850 plus this 139
and then for the finished one
uh the the last scenario where they get
really where we feed them up to 1270
pounds i'm gonna use this hundred and
twenty seven dollars per hundred weight
right here i had to cut this off and and
attach it because the there isn't a ton
of these sales so i'm not sure how
strong this 127 dollars is but uh you
know we could look around if we really
wanted to get more detailed but again
we're projecting because that animal is
going to be on feed for a while so you
could go through with your own budget
there and play with that number that 127
and move it down say seven bucks or up
ten bucks and and it would really uh
make a difference in your bottom line
but for this presentation since we're
already doing multiple scenarios i
didn't
run that so that would be an interesting
thing to do
is once you decide maybe after you watch
this and you do some thinking on your
own operation you decide okay i'm gonna
uh background
525 up to 850 pound steers uh i would go
in there and play with the
expected sale price uh per 100 weight
there at the end
and move that around once you decide on
which scenario suits you best and see
exactly how how much prices can move one
way or another and you still make a
profit or or how much the the loss would
actually be
so here's the 525 to 850 pound scenario
uh a 1.8 pound average daily gain see it
here and this is the ration um that was
put forth and and i have to thank carl
hoppy for putting these uh ration
scenarios together for me based on what
i what i needed him to do
and so he had it uh we've got
10 pounds per head per day in grass hay
17 and silage two and a half pounds of
ddgs
and then a little bit of salt and then
this comes out to about 88 cents a day
for this for this scenario
okay
so then when i put it into the budget
spreadsheet and there's a lot of stuff
when you look at this budget there's a
lot of stuff below this return to labor
is management risk i cut all that off
because what it adds up to are these
these prices in here anyway so i just
this way it fit on the slide better and
you can see it
but
i used that projected selling price of
139. my beginning value was 167 as
you'll recall
and then we got the shrink shrinking
death loss down here so weaned at 525
and we're feeding them up to 850 pounds
that animal is going to be on feed for
180 days to achieve that at a 1.8 pound
average daily gain
and we basically get a profit
of
13.28
so that's that's pretty pretty slim
margin there on backgrounding under this
scenario here this 1.8 pound average
daily gain
all right
so our next scenario is this 500 pound
to 800 pound
steer
and we're gonna feed them to uh achieve
a 2.8 pounds average daily gain and we
see here
that they're gonna again i have this uh
grass legume hay silage corn corn grain
ddgs and then some salt for about 35
pounds total of feed
35.071 if you include the salt
and obviously it's going to be more
expensive to feed this animal per day
at a dollar and six cents estimated cost
to achieve this 2.8 pounds and we're
going from 500 to 800 weight
and then what you have here okay is so
we're starting at this 500 weaning
weight uh the cost is still about 167
dollars that's roughly what it was for
those 500 to 550s for just same
projected selling price
because we're talking about that 800
plus range
feed cost of a dollar six here's my
yardage i always have it highlighted but
that's where it is at that 35 cents so
in this case we're making 72 dollars per
head um by by getting that 2.8 pounds on
there
and while we're selling at similar
weights and we're purchasing at the
similar price
uh putting on all that weight faster
essentially we get a lower yardage cost
not not in uh
cents per day but in total cost because
you see this animal is only on feed for
for a 108 days versus that other one
that was on feed for 180 days right so
then that that yardage fee just keeps
adding up i mean it's 80 percent longer
that you're feeding that animal and the
labor and everything that goes into it
so
what this is showing is that relative to
like yardage costs and other things
feed costs even though corn is higher
are not all that high
they're not prohibitively high so
putting on the weight here is fa faster
actually pays quite a bit more and
you're looking at 72 dollars ahead
and again some some of the stuff i'm
putting in here for costs is
conservative you might be able to do
better um uh
pay uh given what you're going to have
to pay this year
we we try to be
realistic but a little conservative with
some of this so again seventy two
dollars and three cents
okay so this is the the finisher uh
scenario where we're going for a
predicted date average daily gain of 3.6
pounds
um this animal we're going from a 575
way to 1270
and that animal is going to average 34.4
pounds per day
and the dollar per head per day
obviously is quite a bit higher at a
dollar 53 a day
so
this this critter is going to be on feed
for quite a while to get there and it's
going to be a fairly um
strong ration to be able to achieve 3.6
pounds per day
and here it is uh broken out on on the
spreadsheet and so this projected
selling price changes
to
127 dollars per hundred weight so less
than the others because because he's
heavier
the beginning value is a little bit
lower
because it's in the 575 you're getting
close to the 600 weight category so
that's 127 dollars right now
this animal is going to be on feed for
193 days to achieve 1270
to go from 575 to
12 70 193 days but the profit on this is
almost 250 dollars ahead
so it the animal is on feed for a long
time this steer is but you're putting on
a lot of weight
and so this is this is again showing
that being able to put the weight on
right now is definitely profitable and
you're talking about two hundred and
fifty dollars ahead uh profit uh by by
feeding this animal all the way out to
1270 pounds
at a very hot ration now
i don't i don't have this scenario run
but i can guarantee you if you drop this
3.6
to a lower value 2.8 or 1.8 or something
like that and then he has to stay on
feed a whole lot longer this profit will
go down quite a bit
so right now it's showing definitely
that it pays
to to
put the weight on as quickly as possible
so then the next three scenarios we're
going to go through and and again i'm
gonna at the end i have a table that i'm
gonna show that compares all six
scenarios so we can look at them side by
side as i go through this but in this uh
the next three are going to be a heifer
backgrounding scenarios that uh
carl hoppy also put the put the feed
ration together for me uh and and i'm
gonna go through the same budgetary
budgetary discussion with this
so
media i use that same
usda auction prices for the week ending
november 13th in north dakota this is
what i have
nothing really over 766 weights so i
have to
finish it out there i'll use that price
and then for the um
the values or the costs of retaining the
animal or going and buying them
that obviously comes in here quite a bit
cheaper than steers right now
the price slide for heifers was pretty
pretty severe this fall
with you know almost 30 40 difference
between heifers and steers per hundred
weight right now
so our first scenario were heifers from
450 to 750 pounds at a 1.8 pounds per
day
uh 28 pounds of feed comes out to about
83 cents per head per day in feed cost
so putting on 300 pounds 1.8 pound per
day at about 83 cents in feed costs
and so here's that heifer scenario
and
what we wind up with we're beginning
value at 126. i'm using the same shrink
and the same death loss
finished out at 750 and then headed down
the road sale price at 113 dollars per
hundredweight
and we wind up with a profit of about 28
bucks per head in this case so
profitable definitely uh always always
better when this is above zero than
below it but not terribly lucrative in
this case where you're talking about
barely thirty dollars per head
but again it's kind of a theme that
we're that that i'm showing in this in
this scenario that uh it
it's lower but it's similar to the
steers this these lower
average daily gain rates tend not to be
as profitable as the higher ones as
you'll see
moving forward
but they're putting on and then you know
this animal's on feed for 165 days and
again that's where that yardage of 35
cents
really starts to add up um
so then our next scenario is 525 pounds
to 800 pounds so in this case we're
putting on 275 pounds at that same 1.8
pounds average daily gain animals a
little bigger when we get it so our our
cost per day are higher right out of the
gate
at 90 cents per day and then the ration
of 32 and a half pounds of feed today
with uh with this breakout
so here it is with the the the the
numbers that were plugged in there and
this is actually showing a loss
and the
big reason for that is that
we're only we're making money putting on
the weight and putting on 275 pounds for
this long just isn't enough to pay out
and that's what this is showing here and
i i think i have this scenario uh toward
the end of the presentation that i'm
going to show uh where we where we make
some adjustments real quick to it but
beginning value is about the same
similar
projected sale price is about the same
feed cost a little bit higher a lot cost
the same and 155 days on feed that gets
us a loss of two bucks so
we we really aren't putting on enough
weight in this scenario fast enough to
actually pay off is is what this is
showing
and then our final heifer scenario is
550 to 850 pounds back to uh 300 pounds
that we're putting on the animal at a
2.8 pounds uh per day so quite uh higher
than the 1.8 before
this is more expensive again per day at
a dollar eight which which should be
obvious because we're putting on more
weight and here's the pounds of feed per
day and the breakout there a lot of
silage uh for this in this particular
scenario again put together by uh carl
hoppy for for this uh for this talk
but this is our uh final heifer scenario
there
and then here is the breakout of the
heifer scenario here
and
what we got 550 pounds to 850 this
animal's only in the in the yard there
for 107 days a lot a lot shorter period
of time than the other two
uh projected selling price roughly the
same beginning value they didn't change
much between 450 weights and 550 weights
really and 126
feed costs at a hundred a dollar eight
per day and we get down here and the
profit is about sixty two dollars per
head okay so quite a bit higher profit
and
getting to that 850 pounds and the
explanation is again this yardage fee
total cost on yardage is much lower
because we're only at 107 days instead
of 150 or 160 and and that's achieved by
this higher average daily rate of gain
so if you're seeing a theme here
feed costs relative to the value of the
pounds that are being put on is still
relatively low and
enabling us to to make a profit
i'm not even messing with
prices of fed cattle or anything like
that this is just straight up showing
that that putting on the weight uh that
right now despite higher corn prices
it's it pays to put weight on these
animals
so as i said there's a i was going to
put together a profit loss breakdown
that kind of compared them all side by
side and so here's our
three steer examples 1.8 2.8 3.6 average
daily gains
the the varying days on feed
and then you kind of look here to this
column the profit and loss and
uh the more weight we put on or the
faster we put it on the more valuable uh
and the more profit we make so you see
like this this uh fed out steer here
from 575 to 1270 you we're profiting a
dollar 29 per day per head uh doing that
on the 500 to 800 weight at 2.8 pounds
per day we're making 67 cents uh per
head per day profit uh putting the
weight on so that that's pretty solid
and then this 1.8 pounds is is likely
that's almost a break-even proposition
it's just they're the the animals in the
yard too long the yardage fees are
starting to add up too fast and we're
just not putting on enough weight
um so then we come down here to the
heifer scenarios
and you see a similar theme with the
exception of
you know the the first scenarios is
barely a kind of a break even
proposition
the second scenario for all intents and
purposes i know it shows a negative two
bucks but that's
when you're doing estimates it's pretty
close to zero so these two scenarios
really don't
help us out a lot it's not until we
start putting on
two three pounds a day or more that we
start really seeing a profit
and that's this 550 to 850 weight
example putting on almost three pounds
per day we're netting 58 cents to go up
to 850 pounds okay so
i think you guys are probably by now
getting the theme of all of this which
is that putting on weight as fast as you
can
pays now obviously you do you can't you
there's only so much you can do but
right now that that's that's the theme
through all of the scenarios that i ran
whether it's steers or heifers there it
that it pays to put on weight
not not go cheap or anything like that
you know put the weight on pack on the
pounds and get them out the door as
quickly as possible that's what this is
showing here so that we keep those
yardage and overhead costs that you got
to deal with labor and whatever else
lower
and as i said i had some scenarios so uh
to kind of re emphasize that point and
if we say all else equal what happens if
i keep the 500 weight steer with 2.8
average daily gain to 850 pounds uh
before that we we we had them down to
eight hundred and
look what it does it actually increases
our profit pretty considerably to a
hundred and eight dollars and uh and
instead of what we showed before which i
think was what 67 or something like that
70. so putting adding adding another 50
pounds onto the animal
uh makes sense and the reason is because
this 2.8 pounds average daily gain we're
making money every quite a bit of money
every day that that animal is in the
yard
at 2.8 pound average daily gain
it's sort of a balancing act you're
trying to figure out okay how much is it
costing me to have this critter here in
veterinary and labor and
my own time and everything else
and
versus
what about uh
putting in the feed and
feed costs and being able to to achieve
these higher average daily gains and
what this shows is that 2.8 pounds
you're making money keeping them in the
lot and putting weight on and and the
other example that made quite a bit more
with putting on 3.6 really pays because
you're more than covering overhead and
variable costs and every day that
they're sitting there in the yard
getting bigger you're making money
alright so let's do the same thing with
the heifer uh if we have all else equal
what happens if i keep the 512 25 weight
heifer with a 1.8 pound average daily
gain to 850 and i i believe it went from
a negative two dollars to 15.82 so what
this kind of shows is 1.8 pounds is
uh fairly close to a break even
proposition on heifers we need to get a
we need to have a higher average daily
gain than that
in order to really make a profit yes 1.8
pounds adg is is is above break even
but just barely i mean and we're not
we're that's the margin is too slim in
my opinion
to go with that so i would definitely be
looking at trying to get to that
three pounds per day or better
on all my steers and heifers if i'm
looking to background them and put some
weight on and right now all the all the
cost data and everything else and the
market data is showing that that uh uh
buyers uh are willing to to pay for
weight that that's that's what they're
willing to do and feed costs are low
enough that we can put it on and make a
profit as things stand right now
so some key points to this presentation
uh
i'll reiterate it again it pays to put
on weight so the purchase costs for 500
to 575 way steers are high
but feed costs remain lower or low
relatively low compared to what our
market prices are for eight 800 uh
weight animals all the way up to 12 1200
so
what that says is
you know it that there's money to be
made doing this and then as i as i said
it in the last few slides putting on
weight faster is better because it
reduces your yardage costs as well as
the number of days the animal has to be
managed for every pound gained okay
so that's that's kind of the theme here
is
put on as much weight as reasonably
possible as fast as possible uh and and
you stand to make
as much uh the most amount of money from
from any kind of uh feeding enterprise
so the other key points is you need to
put on at least 300 pounds on heifers
otherwise there just isn't
enough enough there to really make it
worth it so you're gonna want to
if they're 500 pounds feed them up to
eight eight fifty
four hundred fifty pounds up to seven
fifty eight hundred and again you're
gonna wanna do it as fast as possible at
least that 2.8 pound let's call it three
pounds average daily gain i should
definitely be your target so we're
talking about 300 pounds per animal on
the heifer side at three pounds per day
that's that that should be our target
and if we can achieve that
all else holds equal
where we stand to make a decent profit
on on everything we retain and put
weight on so
that's kind of that's good news and and
it's a similar story to what we were
seeing last year that the last couple of
years had they have paid
for for producers to to put weight on
these animals and and we're seeing that
now as well
so with that i'd like to thank everyone
who watched i have my email address here
i didn't put my phone number because
i've been in and out of the office quite
quite often with the
stuff going on with covet and everything
else a lot of working from home hence
the reason we're doing this virtual
versus last year where we did it in
person but thanks to everyone who
watched if there's any questions you can
shoot me an email
as shown here and i'll try to get to it
as a in a timely manner
otherwise i appreciate it and hopefully
next year or here in the somewhat near
future i can start doing some of this
stuff face to face so thank you everyone
and
have a good week